The joe rogan experience.
Is there a a point where you think,
like,
if you look at like your career,
like if you look at your future,
if you like,
will you be,
you say,
okay,
for if I get to this point
done?
No,
no,
no.
You can do it until you enjoy it.
While I stopped enjoying it for years,
I fucking hate it for four years,
four,
five years when I start gambling.
Um,
and then I wouldn't admit I hate it.
I'd have like little spells where I would be like,
I can't do it anymore.
I don't want to,
the pressure,
the fucking head fuck of it,
all the this,
and then when I get my money and money gambling it all,
I just,
uh,
you know,
I mean,
I can't do it anymore and I can't keep bringing myself back up like Kimball,
which might be a big comeback,
uh,
[inaudible],
you know,
keep it going.
Do,
you know,
bought a bean,
that ball it.
Just a lot of bad decisions and so by me as well,
but not just fortunately,
not just bad decisions,
just bad results.
Well,
but results of some caused by me and some,
some just bad decisions to do.
I mean it's not just,
yeah,
the Kimble fight was seen by how many people that must be,
there was a huge audience.
Right.
8 million people are thinking of fancy.
A six or eight.
I can't remember.
I know most people,
what they remember is that you came into the cage with a fucking mouse living in
your hair.
You gotta like a whole mouse family and it blew up.
Right.
And you popped in the middle of the fight.
It was so hard to watch.
That was the most fucked up ear ever seen.
I'm national TV.
No one had a more fucked up here.
My is from a famous I man,
I'm jealous.
Jealous on my end.
We'll talk about that fight when we heard that guy that fuck Kimbo what the
crazy fucking ear.
Oh Shit.
Colossus.
I'm not going to be remembered.
Fall out though for that.
No.
You'll,
you'll be remembered for your entire career of sure.
No,
what I'm saying,
what I'm saying is out the moment.
Remember?
Yeah.
I thought at the moment people would say,
I'm the Kimball.
You know what I remember,
I remember he had Kimbo in side control and he stood you up.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
You know,
I remember that.
Right.
Nobody ever points type.
I always say,
I mean,
I take a lot of mold.
Watch the fucking pizza.
You don't stands a guy up when the guy and I just,
yeah,
a lead x.
He was a corrupt organization.
Corrupt one of them.
They changed the rules.
They told guys to stand up and bang.
They told guys stand up and bang.
They gave them instructions and they made,
they made the referee stand guys up much earlier.
Big country was fighting Andrea [inaudible] and had him in a fucking side
control position and work in a Kamora and they stood in back up.
I'm like,
you gotta be fucking kidding me.
Jake shields as they did that same shit when he was fighting Paul,
um,
uh,
Semtex when he's fighting Paul Daley,
same shit.
They tried to stand them up early,
but Jake just attack,
attack,
attack and got him in an arm bar.
He just went,
Jake's high level black belt.
So he just went after it really quickly.
But you had Kimbo in fucking side control.
You work to get it.
You got it.
You were a dominant position.
He was tired and they stood you back up bitches.
We did a radio interview,
you know,
everyone's on the other line and just finished training.
So I'm on the phone,
I want to,
no one was asking me fucking any questions.
Um,
and I thought,
yeah,
I'm just the Guy Kimbo to be so,
and then someone has to go short question.
They said,
um,
this is how he was holding the phone.
Um,
the Africa each,
all the questions.
I just,
uh,
I did have to say,
so just in case you can visualize it.
And they said to him,
what would you do with James Thompson won?
And he said,
I'd hung myself.
And I thought,
wow,
that's the dumbest motherfucker in the history of MMA productions.
The,
the idea that you have one guy that's the most important thing and bank
everything on him winning so stupid.
Oh,
eggs.
Culturally domino.
Because if you kicked that guy's ass,
it would have been awesome.
If they left you in side control would have been awesome.
Just like it was awesome for him when he won.
It would have been awesome for you then.
You know,
you got to let the guy who's supposed to win win when you're trying to just be
the most marketable.
You're like looking for the most marketable guy.
You'd never going to have a legit organization organization.
This whole organization was,
it was essentially a corrupt organization.
That's,
that's what that is.
Um,
I'm writing a book at the moment because the blogs,
I've gone so well.
I felt to himself,
I'll call it fucking,
I looked beside looking back at the different stories,
kind of take the federal drinking water and everyone loved it.
And a few more.
So I started thinking,
I've got fucking
that,
that elite Exede stories are very important story from martial arts because that
made me angry.
I was watching that at home and I was angry.
I was like,
this is crazy.
And I love Kimbo.
I think he's an awesome guy.
He's a great character.
I like watching him fight.
He won a boxing match recently.
He's been winning a lot of boxing matches.
I love that dude.
It's not that I wanted him to win or you to win,
but I wanted fairness.
And you worked hard to get to that position and you were in a dominant position
and they stood you back up and you were fucking tired and you've got cracked.
And they did the same thing with big country when big country had our Lawsky
down.
He was working for a fucking Komora and they stood him up.
I'm like,
are you crazy?
It was quite ironic.
Um,
I watched a big country.
I mean,
he was almost in exactly the same position as me when he beat Kimball on the,
yeah.
Uh,
you know,
Kinda not mentioned or no,
very close to the same position,
you know what I mean?
The only difference is he went with the mountain.
He had a full amount of crucifixions by,
you know,
which I'm sure you could have worked towards.
You had him on his back.
He was only going to get more tired.
There was a couple minutes to go
[inaudible] without Phi.
It's not that.
I think they should have stopped the fight because he came back and he,
yeah,
and he was atomy rocked in the third round.
He barely fucking up them,
uh,
punches.
And I was,
I was rocked.
So it's not bad,
but they should have said,
you might knock me out.
I don't know.
I know man.
I took him down.
Right.
I don't know what a warm right.
That's a fucking,
the point of the fight.
You've got to let the fight conclude.
He could've knocked me out.
Make,
cause I was,
I was at one more tape down and he,
and he was mine.
Well,
you take such a good shot and you take so many shots that sometimes people don't
know what the fuck to do.
And I think a fight like that,
like you took some bombs from Timbo and you were still there.
And it's like the referees like,
man,
do I rescue this fucking guy?
It's a weird judgment call.
And it's very important to have the right referee in a situation like that.
Like a guy like herb dean,
he'll,
he'll let you fight,
he'll let you fight if he,
but he will save you if he knows you're fucked,
you know?
And that,
that I think there's a lot of fights where the referee errs on the side of
caution and protects the fighter.
And in a case like yours,
you feel like you were denied an opportunity because of that.
Right?
Right.
Yeah.
Well what I was saying before,
so I was I van Berlin,
but the,
I was backstage and it just happened on a gallery show sharks on that fucking a
big cheer.
Scala as though they call them.
Oh yeah.
Scholar.
What seems like a nice guy with a fucking motel.
Dolla sign.
Fucking yeah.
Is a chain of dog sign chain.
Ah,
oh,
the ss a scholar.
Yeah.
It's clever.
Well he grew up with the rich dad and he is an interesting way to live your
life.
But he came up to me and he said,
you've got to go to the hospital.
You've got to do it.
Well,
it's the hospital now.
I know you've got to go to the hospital.
Yeah,
I'm okay.
I turned to him and I said,
yeah.
I said,
yeah,
but he turned away or,
you know,
cause there's a lot going on.
I may turn back and when you have to go to the hospital now I'm taking you now
and I,
you really want me to go to the hospital,
right?
Too much.
So then I went to the Pratt conference instead,
and as I walked into the past conference,
go show was going,
we've just had to take James Thompson to the hospital
grieving.
And I'm the,
I'm someone caught into it and I was drinking a drink.
And I think
that sums it all up there.
Corella on words.
Yeah.
That's a corrupt organization.
That's horse shit.
They're pretending you were hurt more than you were to pump Kimbo up.
Yeah.
Wow.
That's interesting.
Yeah.
[inaudible].